et mexes et toi il faut croire que oui
trop fort tu vas être entraîneur de
football c'est devenu une légende en
faisant un choix tellement con il vaut
de faire la misère
nous mêmes nous arrive depuis l'autre
côté de l'atlantique lives et richmond a
annoncé le nom de son nouvel entraîneur
qui n'est autre que théodore dit est de
l'assaut vous êtes un américain qui va
entraîner une équipe de football de
ligue 1 même si votre connaissance du
jeu est très limité je sais que cette
asi richmond se donnera à fond qu'il
mène où qu'il soit mené ou à égalité
je pense qu'il vit en angleterre j'ai
raison pays de galles
c'est un autre pays oui et non mais
combien y at il deux pays dans ce pays 4
que ça vous plaise ou non richmond va
changer sa façon de faire à partir de
maintenant c'est l'assaut qui donne la
rotation et c'est dingue cette voiture
un volant invisible ce que vous faites
c'est irresponsable
ce club compte beaucoup pour les gens de
cette ville ouais je sais ça c'est un
phénomène
je crois que c'est ça le vrai défi
embrasser le changement eric et faire
preuve de courage
notre décision de m j'ai mis sur le banc
de 12,7 et courageuse attention aux
propos tendancieux au travail pour moi
le succès ne dépend pas des victoires ou
des défaites pour moi le succès c'est
d'aider ces jeunes à devenir une
meilleure version 2 mène sur ou en
dehors du terrain
[Musique]
j'ai toujours cru que le thé n'était
rien d'autre que de l'eau chaude marot
eh bien vous savez quoi
j'avais raison c'est immonde non merci
bienvenue en angleterre
[Musique]